these neighboring troughs and Peaks as a
good approximation of where the finger
starts and ends and then we can trace a
long ways to finally create a hand pose
and that hand pose we can then use as a
driver for input for games so we can
work out if the things are extended if
they're closed the system just uses the
Nintendo Wiimote from the way it
connects to the computer via bluetooth
for markers on the end of the fingertip
so then picked up by a camera on the
Nintendo Wiimote it's an infrared camera
and the system utilizes a library
developed by Brian Peake called Wii mote
live which is freely available via
CodePlex
we built the three-dimensional tracking
capability on top of that library it
uses plane of holography to be able to
work out where the points are in 3d
space so you have a plane at the front
and a plane at the back and we do an
intersection of lines to each of the
LEDs via those two planes and we can
work out where things are in 3d there
are four LEDs on the end of the fingers
they are powered by this unit on the
back here essentially it's a USB
rechargeable unit as well when the kits
out in the home that you can just plug
it into the PC and charge it via the PC
the Glovers has been designed so we can
swap for different sized finger pieces
so we can detach and reattach it up
there so for different users we can use
different lengths of wire we can also
use individual finger attachments as
well the games which you can see on on
the screen are essentially they're
produced in Microsoft's XNA framework
which is a game development framework
which people can also use to distribute
to Xbox 360
around 15 million people have a stroke
every year the kind of movements people
have to make post-stroke off pronation
supination reach to grasp and then grasp
pick an object up and put it down in
another place have the peg test where
you have to pinch pick up and drop down
and what we've done is we've mapped that
interaction to pinch and release like so
so if I just show you that now
essentially what I do is I pinch to
activate the ball and then I release to
defy the ball there's a fun and
interesting project to do the main
difficulties I would say would be
actually building a system which can be
deployed into the home so rather than
having a system which just works in a
research lab we had to actually make it
so it was robust enough to work in the
real world environment and that's where
the that the difficulty came in as far
as coding and that sort of thing goes so
Paul the problems that we had with this
system were things like a phantom IR
reflection so this works off a series of
infrared emitting diodes we're getting
other infrared sources from around the
house such as perhaps a television
remote if you're wearing a glove there
might be patient discomfort there might
be hygiene issues you might find it
difficult to get the glove on there's
lots of little technical parts on the
glove which can get broken so we're
looking at whether we can use the Kinect
camera as a marker 'la system where you
don't have to wear anything at all for
fast and robust tracking in a home
environment or what we've got in front
of us now is essentially a hand tracking
system that takes advantage of the depth
map features of the Kinect camera so in
computer vision research traditionally
has been a lot of background in using
color based cameras to extract people's
hands and hand pose information from a
scene and they work really really well
in a tightly controlled lab setting so
when you've got things like green screen
very tight control of the lighting
conditions but that doesn't translate
well into a real home setting and a
practical kind of view scenario for a
home-based drug rehabilitation system
now the advantage of the Kinect is that
instead of giving you a color feed
yeah actually gives you a depth map of
the scene so instead of having color
information encoded in pic
encourage the distance in millimeters of
each pixel in the scene and it's much
more tolerant to environmental
conditions and things like skin tone
this is a proof-of-concept game designed
to test the tracking system so it's
based on the slingshot game we saw
earlier using the Wemo and this is
designed to try the exercise and arm
synergy so we're using the shoulder
elbow that reach and the pinching grasp
the game randomly positions a ball on
the screen and you just need to move my
hand over the ball grab it and throw to
the target and then a ball will reappear
and we've got kind of a developer mode
to help us see what's going on so you
can see it's finding kind of that large
red circle which is really the key
element of the hand tracking works
trying to find the center of the palm we
then try to look at nearby information
to determine fingertips pits of the
fingers and we can use that to
eventually create these kind of purple
lines that we can trace along to find
the depth information about the fingers
and from that calculator hunt pose we
essentially locate the hand in the scene
segment all the other informations
remove everything we're not interested
in background your arm your face so
you've only got the hand left on the
depth map we then trace around that hand
contour so you create kind of a contour
route around the outside of your hand
and this helps account for a lot of the
missing information so you might have
blank spots within the end but because
we're now only looking at the contour we
kind of eliminate all those we then try
and find the largest area we're inside
that contour because that invariably
turns out to be the palm of the hand we
then do some distance analysis of the
contour away from the center of the palm
we do some filtering to smooth that out
and this helps us classify a distance
graph into peaks and troughs and we then
classified maximal points as fingertips
and minimal points is finger troughs and
we can simply use neighboring troughs
and Peaks as a good approximation of
where the finger starts and ends and
then we can trace along ways to finally
create a hand pose and that hand pose we
can then use the driver input for games
so we can work out if the things are
extended if they're closed
ok so connect is a novel database camera
so it uses a
structured lights approach so instead of
actually just being one camera that you
might think of traditionally it has an
infrared projector so it's projecting a
pattern in infrared light onto
everything in the scene that we can't
see it then uses an infrared camera to
look at that pattern and it looks for
distortions in the pattern and
eventually uses triangulation to
calculate the depth in the scene the
downside to that is that it's not
particularly accurate we have done some
experiments to try and verify the
accuracy because we're using it for
clinical purposes also things generate a
lot of missing information especially on
small objects which is quite a big
problem when you're looking at something
like the hand because fingertips can
quite often disappear now a
time-of-flight camera like this one I
have here has traditionally been a lot
more expensive so this cameras in the
region of several thousand pounds to buy
but this actually projects infrared
light and measures the time it takes for
it to travel back into the camera so
that creates a much more accurate depth
map because it's not reliant on other
information and the size of objects
within the scene the connect to camera
is reported to use a very very similar
coming to this I believe the camera
develops even by the same company so
we're really excited to see kind of what
we'll be able to do move the same kind
of technology and low-cost
camera as a Kinect that's definitely
suitable for home use because it's
designed for playing games in the home
but with the kind of the accuracy we've
got ustah from these kind of cameras a
camera like this which traditionally
cost between two to four thousand pounds
so they these are the kind of cameras
that have been applied for industrial
use in production lines and monitoring
but the Kinect really revolutionized the
depth camera scene so it was the the
first kind of real low-cost consumer
available that camera available and it's
had a huge impact on computer vision
technology just getting better and
better and I think it will make a huge
impact not just on our research team
bond the kind of that this whole field
in general connect to will be out at
Christmas with the launch of the new
Xbox one but we're hoping that we can
get on the developer list so there is a
list of people to get the SDK early if
they're doing interesting enough
projects
so hopefully you
I think it realizing something like
photon shift that really I'm more
interested in using it then I leave that
to physicists to work out and it's where
they can write some code show me your
code and I can give you a job